- How is dating?
'Cause now that you know,
things are coming back to normal,
do you use apps?
Are you into..
- Oh, I'm on so many apps and I gotta say
dating's bad.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
It's not good.
- It's still, it's still bad.
- It's awful.
You're like, I just,
the apps are terrible.
The men are just trash.
Not to be rude, but like..
- Okay that's honest.
- [Nicole] Yes, I'm being very honest.
- Keeping it real.
- This one man on the app, he was like,
let me buy you something expensive,
and I was like, ooh, a vintage car?
And then he unmatched me,
(audience laughs)
and I was like, why did you offer?
You know?
- It's your problem.
- [Nicole] Yeah.
- I see this as a, you problem.
- [Nicole] Yes.
Another man had screenshots
of his bank account.
And I was like..
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah.
And so I picked a number
higher than what he had posted.
And I was like, I only talked to men
with this amount of money.
And he's like, I have more!
And I was like, sir,
you're thirsty in a way
that I don't like.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
That's desperation.
- Yeah.
More desperate than me..
- You know what's kind of
cool about that though?
You really weed out,
you don't waste your time.
- No.
- Yeah, you can really weed..
I've never thought about it that way.
- Yes, yeah, my time's very valuable.
- Yeah, and..
(audience laughs)
It is though, it's like,
if I'm gonna take a minute to go out,
look, I, we're busy people.
- [Nicole] Yeah.
- Yeah.
How did you decide what pictures to post?
And what to write in your dating profile?
'Cause I feel like you
gotta be honest, right?
- [Nicole] Yes.
- 'Cause you're gonna show up,
they're gonna see you.
They're gonna know.
Yeah.
- [Nicole] Yeah.
So I show the whole body,
let them know that I'm
a big gal, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, my profile says I'm a THOT.
And then I say, the happiest out there.
- The happiest out there?
- Yeah.
- That's not what it..
- That's not what..
- That's not what it
stands for? (Kelly laughs)
- [Nicole] No, I chose a
different word for the acronym.
- I love it.
- Also it says, I love to tee-hee-hee,
'cause I love to laugh.
And then I said, "Fat, yet flexible."
(Kelly and audience laughs)
You know, you just gotta let them know.
- Yeah.
But you got to be honest, you know right?
So you do that.
I like that.
- [Nicole] I do have a
picture of me doing a split,
on a hot dog held by Guy Fieri, somewhat.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
This is, I'm going to be honest with you,
if I'm, if I'm a dude,
or whatever your into, if a girl,
if I'm flipping through and I'm like,
that's someone I want to date.
- [Nicole] Right?
- That's funny.
- [Nicole] She's fun.
- She's fun.
- She's flexible, she loves Guy Fieri.
- Yeah.
- He's a great person,
I wish he was single.
(Kelly laughs)
He's not.